افادت مشاهدينا وسائل اعلام امريكيه
بمحاصره منزل المشتبه به في قضيه تسريب
وثائق الكونغرس بعد عاصفه من الجدل والقلق
اثرتها تسريب هذه الوثائق السريه للغايه
وكانت واحده من اكبر الكوابيس الدبلوماسيه
والامنيه لواشنطن مؤخرا لكن المفاجاه
الاكبر هنا هي ان مسرب وثائق البنتا مجرد
شاب عشريني غاضب بدا مشوار مسرب وثائق
البنتاغون المعروف بلقب اوجي عبر منصه
للالعاب الالكترونيه برفقه 20 من رفاقه
ممن يؤمنون بنظريه المؤامره حسب طبعا ما
كشفه تقرير امريكي عن هذا الشاب هذا
المسرب الشاب مشاهدينا مولع بالاسلحه
الناريه وكان يعمل في قاعده عسكريه وذلك
نقلا عن زملائه في مجموعه دردشه على
الانترنت وفقا هنا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست
الامريكيه نشر المسرب الوثائق وثائق
البنتاجون جزءا من هذه الملفات الحساسه
العام الماضي وقال لزملائه في المجموعه
انه حصل عليها خلال عمله في قاعده عسكريه
لم يحددها تلاها بعد هذه العمليه نشر مئات
الرسائل طوال اشهر منها مقتطفات
استخباراتيه سريه وتضمنت الوثائق المنشوره
معلومات عن مكان وتحركات قاده سياسيين
رفيعي المستوى وتحديثات تكتيكيه عن القوات
العسكريه وتحليلات جيو سياسيه وتحليلات عن
جهود الحكومات الاجنبيه للتدخل في نتائج
الانتخابات وما هي الا جزء صغير جدا من
سيل الاسرار فكان اجي يخطط لنشر المئات
منها هنا السلطات الامريكيه والبنتاجون
اطلقات تحقيقا خاصا ادى للوصول لبعض
الخيوط التي قد تساعد في القاء القبض على
مسرب الوثائق منها طبعا مقطع فيديو له
ظهر في خلفيته بعض الصور والادله التي
يمكن للمحققين استخدامها في اجراءاتهم مثل
اثاث واغراض وغيرها ما ظهر طبعا بهذا
الفيديو
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات